i am finding out in this time that how
terrible i am at tech
because in addition to making the shows
i do podcasts and i have to and zoom
sessions with writers and i they're
always trying to talk me through
how to get on my computer and i've come
to realize
at this later stage in my life that i'm
awful
i'm the worst how are you at this
terrible
and i have no excuse i i was born in the
age of the
yeah well not born i lived a young life
in the age of the internet
i feel like more is expected from me yes
i have so many i have an excuse i have
an excuse i was born in 1944
you
the computer you know i saw my first
computer we
it's i had the steam-powered kind that
you could crank in college
and so this is newer to me you have
no excuse you have no excuse for being
attacked
but it's changing so fast i feel like
i've gotten i'm
in this time i'm getting a crash course
and how every grandparent has felt for
the last 20 some odd years
but there's so many different platforms
there's so many ways
to screw it up i accidentally got a new
computer and was trying to you know put
all the old stuff on the new thing and
accidentally
disposed of a bunch of important files
just permanently deleted them
the things that run the thing off the
computer i don't know how to send
i can't remember to say this i don't
know how to send emails from a computer
i only know wait a minute that's just
wait a minute no
that's yes yes you can
yes you can you can do it but you
but the way that it's displayed and the
chains and i can't figure out how to
respond to the right female in the chain
i just it's it's bad it's really bad i'm
sorry you are worse than i thought
i can send an email and receive an email
um that's about it that's all i can do
but i'm but the fact that you're
struggling with that means
there's other i mean i have 13 000
unread emails so i'm
it's reaching a dire breaking point over
here do you have
um people in your family like are your
parents
like my my dad actually is is really up
there but he
can he's pretty good at a computer my
mother never even tried
is your mom any good at this stuff i was
just about to say
so my dad right there with me my mom
undercover internet sleuth like
undercover could maybe work for the
government level of
internet sleuth she has i
i some kind of wicked google alert out
there on me
she sees everything and anything most of
the time
before i've seen it or become aware of
it my mother though has started doing
this thing where she finds she finds
everything but she knows that i don't
know how to find
most of it so she will um for example if
somebody is being quite rude about an
outfit that i wore on a red carpet
you know she takes that kind of
personally and i think she wants to help
me so she'll
she'll call me and she'll go uh she'll
go you know
rachel i thought you looked so beautiful
last night i loved your dress
i loved the color i just thought that
maybe if you had worn
a different shoe say a strappy sandal
or or a or a bracelet a different
accessory it would have really popped
meanwhile i'm getting
simultaneously tweeted at by the website
going if she just worn a different shoe
a strappy sandal or a bracelet
i'm actually like mother yes mother
first of all i love it you call her
mother
mother please um i
i can go i can top that with because
my mother back in the day and she
wouldn't get this off the internet but
she would
read things in the paper that were not
nice about me
and then she would call me and she'd say
well i don't care and it was stuff that
i would not have seen
because i'm probably like you i don't
read stuff about myself
you know and she's not the mean stuff
exactly and my mother
who was well intentioned would call me
up and go well i don't care what they
say
i don't think you're shrill and unfunny
[Laughter]
mom i didn't know and she'd be like well
apparently the boston herald tribune
thinks so
but that's the last time i read their
paper and i'm like well okay now i know
too and i feel like [ __ ] so everybody's
happy everybody's content
i am glad for that reason i i know it
enough unfortunately to see the
to see the mean tweets and the good
tweets and you know to have figured out
that they all cancel each other out but
it's gotta be so hard for parents
it's gonna be so hard for parents no
matter who you are
or what you do if you have if you're
public facing in any way
people are gonna be mean oh i know i
don't know how i mean
first uh you know if i have two kids who
are
17 and 15 and if someone wrote something
mean about them they're not in the
public eye but if i even heard about
saying someone something
something mean about them i'd go crazy
uh
my parents seemed oddly okay with it
[Laughter]
no one could be meaner than paper